I move here is zero pressure then
you aggressive
here I'm
get Bo avoid
again here he's got a lot of pressure
here on the hand you see
so he collapsed my hand so I let it
collapse right on Tristan I was able to
get it here but he collapsed the hand I
let it collapse
okay know we were fine I just want to
point that out there it is he's he's
trapped I don't push back on that I let
it go and I yielded it okay he's he
would feel that you feel that okay he's
going to counter it there he goes all
right now he's going to push on me and
on yield there it is right here you see
okay so in the same
way that I make an adjustment to his
pressure you see to get that to go or in
the same way that my step out so take
that pressure push there it is that
pressure had I have been able to step
out you see it
neutralized or take the pressure right
and I go this way and then that way I
I'm changing it with my steps my
rotations the right foot the left foot
okay same exact way as I go
here don't have a universal technique
here okay so I increase the Yang value
internalizing it you see and then I
decide what will work within this okay
don't have one that has the same thing
every time your arm is so low that I'm
using muscle to pick that up you see so
as I go I drive
here you see that difference
definitely smash your face and then
break your arm and stomp on your head it
it's fine it works do you get it yes so
obey the values that you're feeling
don't have a technique
okay boom
and it's
quick if your elbows hit it hit
it okay try
[Music]
ad
that stop throwing regain get you to put
your C
yes there it is Bove in in here
[Music]
now my strike in I
will
in
place but when there's no inertia that's
when that becomes a break okay so it's
here back into the face it's here Bo
snap here okay and he he goes into this
KNE here crap don't throw it but show it